so I tweet out this photo of myself okay
I'm in I'm holding coffee I'm tapas and
just underwear and it goes viral and
that's when I learned the word you don't
want people to use when a nude photo of
you goes viral brave welcome back to cBS
we had a new photo go viral
John Dickerson black not since breakfast
I was born a me Schumer is a claim for
her Ross sense of humor on stage she's
also known for her Emmy winning sketch
comedy show inside Amy Schumer and roles
in movies like trainwreck and snatched
in her new movie it's called
I feel pretty Schumer plays Renee she's
an ordinary employee at a cosmetics
company after she suffers a head injury
Renee gains the confidence of a
supermodel Renee taught me what's in the
online division oh yeah but I figure I
can be real with you guys like Gayle
King real and say that it would be a
shame to waste all this in a tiny china
town office I think we've got more of a
front-of-house situation on our hands
am I right or wrong mm-hmm yeah Renee
via panting real no it was coming that
was so cool we're getting a Gayle King
real reaction that was that was very
cool thank you Amy Schumer we met her at
a fishbowl bar in New York City's dream
hotel hotel as how it's pronounced we
discussed a new romantic comedy finding
her own confidence and her comedy roots
I feel pretty and witty and gay gay and
I pity
I feel pretty is a title Amy Schumer
says is meant to send a message
so sizing is a little limited here in
the store
but you could probably find your size
online in the movie she plays Rene a
young woman struggling with self doubt
and insecurity I've been on all of these
sites
no one even looks at the profile they
only care about the picture and I'm sick
of it that is until an accident you hit
your head pretty hard where she wakes up
seeing herself in a whole new light I
said do not retouch me in this movie do
you know you touch anything yeah you see
my cellulite yeah my my rolls or
whatever yes it's like I feel great and
I just want I want other women other
people to feel good about themselves and
I think walking out of this movie you
really do you do Amy wouldn't it be
great if cottage cheese cellulite thighs
could be the Norman beat that's that's
the girl I'm looking for okay that is
the norm Drake has a great line and a
song that he's saying is about you get
on the scale and you worry about the
pounds and men never notice right and
then Kendrick has that line like I want
to see the he's tired of the Photoshop
he wants cellulite stretch marks I'm
like well you got backlash on Twitter
from the first trailers one person said
did Amy Schumer really think a movie
about a woman needing a blow to the head
to feel confident in her body would
uplift people that's a great question
and they say oh that's saying a woman
needs a brain injury to feel confident
and you know what that's a huge
exaggeration and a metaphor but
basically we all struggle with
self-esteem and when they see the movie
I
I know they'll understand DJ hit it
you do seem to feel very comfortable in
your own skin yeah you do yeah too
comfortable because most people would
say well you could take out a little
roll or you could take out a little
piece I'm done with that I'm done I mean
I never use I don't even know how to do
those things on Instagram you know when
they'll call someone out yes for the
last couple of years have just really
felt good about myself and haven't tried
to adjust you know but Amy Schumer what
did it take for you to get there it's a
series of many events but also getting
so much hate online you know being a
woman who uses her voice and expresses
views that that people disagree with
immediately they go to your appearance I
think a lot of women they don't use
their full potential their full voices
because they're afraid of being insulted
was it a journey for you to get to this
I think journey is the appropriate word
it's a it's a constant battle and and
journey and process I I felt really good
about myself as a little girl I didn't
even think about it when did it change
that you thought no I'm questioning how
I look how I move in the world my friend
in fifth grade was like you have a big
butt and I was just like I do I do you
know and yeah you just don't think about
that your body is different from anyone
elses even as a little kid you were fine
being outspoken always like so my
friend's parents may be like Miss
becoming mrs. cowan and I'd be like
Sharon I'd love an orange juice you know
I know and they're like that's
disrespectful I'm like why or I would
say you know mister livingstone I think
you've had too much to drink I don't
think you should drive we're always
raised to call our friends parents mr.
and mrs. so-and-so yeah I was raised to
do that too but I just didn't did you
know that you wanted to make people
laugh
I did a play when I was five I was a
gretel-ann sound of music
and anytime I would talk they would
laugh and to me I'm just saying my line
and I felt kind of humiliated and the
director explained to me
no this they're laughing because you're
funny and they love you I always wanted
to make people laugh and I didn't know
what I was gonna wind up doing but I
knew I would be performing in some way
when I was doing my first movie
trainwreck before I did anything they
said somebody explained to me they were
like to see you know Amy no pressure but
if you weigh over 140 pounds it will
hurt people's eyes your life experiences
seem to have given you really great
materials yeah is it painful for you to
talk about yourself yet such a personal
way sometimes definitely I think
comedians I think they're born funny but
I it's it's a defense mechanism I think
the things that start out the most
painful or humiliating or what you turn
into
comedy and material imagine you take
your clothes off in front of someone for
the first time and they're just like
damn you look mad brave right now Dave
Chappelle once said I was interviewing
him I said is there a line in comedy
that you won't cross and he said to me
you know the line in comedy is always
changing yeah there are things that I
would have joked about even a year ago
that I wouldn't now just with the times
changing and so yeah you know with with
the me to movement happening I don't
want to risk setting anything back I
don't want to risk hurting their
feelings but even like you know when I
started I was playing a character when I
started doing stand-up it was like this
real bubbly or reverent girl who didn't
really know anything was wrong with what
she was saying oh that was insanely
racist you're right you're right
I love joking about race it's like my
favorite it wasn't me it was like me
making fun of someone who's you know
privileged racist you weren't playing
you know and and now I'm as close to
myself as I've ever been on stage but
Amy don't you think people thought that
was you in the beginning in the
beginning I don't well I don't know I
don't think so but well once I realized
I was running the risk of people
laughing for the wrong reasons then I
changed my tune my performance would be
a little affected and sort of talking
different and then delivering my
punchlines like like a bubbly fool I
don't feel like I need to you know dress
like a real housewife Federal Union
anymore no offense ladies let me just
say Amy Schumer is living her best life
last month I was at a party was Ellen
DeGeneres's birthday party and I went up
to Amy and we were talking she said
Gayle see that guy over there and this
was Saturday night I'm gonna marry him
on Tuesday and I thought I was being
Punk'd I went up to the guy and I said
hi are you gonna marry Amy Schumer on
Tuesday goes yes as a matter of fact I
am they did get married on Tuesday so
she is a newlywed her husband's name is
Chris Fisher she is a chef he's a chef
and she's happy and I feel pretty opens
on tomorrow I can't wait to see it she's
very very funny
great interview yeah it's a good movie a
great movie fun movie